or changhua a typical Colombian fish in
the region of the Andes convene America
and vagyok ax and people have it for
breakfast yes usually and after a
hangover
do you ever remember giving me Chango
when I had a hangover so ha ha ha oh
it's too shocked I was too worried
suffer to think about
Oh my daughters having a hangover no I
should have felt I thought I should have
thought about the changhua but I didn't
well now I can make it myself
yeah no you can make it isn't simple who
made John before you sing Bakley
remember my first Chang what was at my
grandmother's from my mother sigh I
never saw her actually cooking the Chang
WA I would always have the Chang well
ready in my bowl when it was them I
think of all these amazing things that
you make and I so rarely watch you make
them they just appear magically in front
of me that's the magic of moms you want
your kid to feel Oh mom this is so good
that you feel like it Queen when you
keep saying that came up yeah I love it
it's so good yeah I did good reel of
Chandra